les lâches sont sur serge boivin est
devenu par la force des choses un
agriculteur à temps partiel depuis
quelques mois il consacre une grande
partie de son temps à sa préparation
pour le iron man 2 dimanche à tremblant
ce que je voulais c'était de pour sita
ma forme physique du lait pendant soin
de moi et puis de me trouver un objectif
qui ne ferait que je ça motiverait
demande réunir autrement dit de prendre
soin de ma santé
avec plus de 300 vaches et 220 hectares
en culture
il peut heureusement compter sur l'appui
de son entourage mallet très très
courageux et surtout la ferme c'est très
très de mandales est ce que ça vous
donne plus de travail vous ben c'est sûr
on doit donner un thème bouchées double
mère ça suce pas bien on gagne
serge a besoin de défis
c'est un défi que s'est donné fait que
je pense ça change des jo à tout les
jours je sous l'effet de de s'entraîner
ici dans les deux derniers moore après
les semences logique j'ai fait une
moyenne de 14 heures d'entraînement 14 à
15 heures d'entraînement par semaine
d'abord trois points 8 km de natation
puis 180 km de vélo et un marathon de
42,2 km de course à pied voilà le défi
qui l'attend je trouve que c'est des
finances permet d'aller de découvrir des
choses sur soi même
je pense que dans deux mois je
recherchais des possibilités que je
connaissais pas
il y a deux ans serge boivin a complété
le demi ironman de tremblant et l'an
dernier il a gravi le kilimandjaro avec
sa conjointe
il se dit prêt à relever ce nouveau défi
et devenir un ironman pour le reste de
sa vie
mais c'est vrai quand on le fait une
fois l'ironman en iran devant toute la
vie je pense que je voyais si je réussis
à dimanche vous êtes très violent ce
producteur laitier veut réussir ce défi
surhumain une fois dans sa vie en étant
inférieure à 13 heures ici jean arel
radio canada kouassi koko